in the united states one in five
patients
hospitalized is re-hospitalized within
30 days of discharge
the question is why do some hospitals
have very low readmission rates relative
while other hospitals have much higher
readmission rates to investigate this
issue we looked at the diagnoses and
timing of hospital readmissions at the
highest performing hospitals in the u.s
with the lowest readmission rates
and compared them to the diagnoses and
timing of readmissions and the lowest
performing hospitals in the u.s with
much higher readmission
we essentially found that readmission
diagnoses and timing
are very similar regardless of hospital
performance
the implication here is that if you want
to reduce your readmissions at your own
hospital think about broad strategies
that can be used to reduce readmissions
across diagnostic categories and time
periods after discharge
rather than focusing on specific
diagnoses and time periods after
discharge because empirically in the
united states
the best performing hospitals have
reduced readmissions across the board